[Música]
nuevo bloque económico aquí en directo
América de France 24 me acompaña nuestra
editora de economía Daniela Blandón Dani
vamos a comenzar hablando de Twitter
porque abrió la puerta monetizar esta
red social Hola Juan pues es sin ofrecer
detalles como desde cuándo lo hará por
ejemplo el dueño de la plataforma elon
musk dijo en su cuenta personal que los
usuarios podrán cobrar por acceso a Su
contenido y que Durante los primeros 12
meses la empresa no se quedará con nada
del dinero que los usuarios ganen por
estas suscripciones eso significa que
mantendrán alrededor del 70% de sus
ingresos en dispositivos móviles después
de descontar lo que cobran a poli Google
en sus tiendas de aplicaciones o más del
90% si lo hacen en la página web Dani
para nuestra audiencia Cómo puede ya
desde la gente ir buscando esta
herramienta pues estos contenidos que
podrán comenzarse a cobrar mediante la
pestaña monetización podrán encontrarse
en la sección de configuración y podrán
inclu textos largos y vídeos de horas de
duración Y es que mosca ha venido
realizando cambios para aumentar los
ingresos tras el desplome de la
publicidad del año pasado antes de que
comprara la red social uno de ellos fue
el cobro por tener las cuentas
verificadas algo que yo no por lo que yo
personalmente no pagaría tampoco cierto
el fondo monetario internacional hizo
recomendaciones de política fiscal para
América Latina Pues en sus reuniones de
primavera conjuntas con el Banco Mundial
este prestamista dijo que los países de
latinoamérica deberían poner en marcha
políticas más estrictas subiendo por
ejemplo Y esto es bien polémico los
impuestos a los ricos De esta manera
podrían contener la alta inflación y
quitarles así algo de peso a los bancos
centrales que tienen sobre sus hombros
hoy la responsabilidad de mover las
tasas de interés para controlar los
precios este organismo puso especial
énfasis en Chile del que espera un
crecimiento negativo este año y del que
dice necesita una reforma Fi lo antes
posible Aunque hay que recordar que el 8
de marzo la cámara de diputados se
rechazó la reforma tributaria del
presidente Gabriel boriche la conclusión
Entonces es que el fondo monetario
internacional Espera que los tipos de
interés en toda la región se mantengan
elevados durante gran parte de este año
y en algunos países inclusive en 2024 y
la otra mala noticia Es que la inflación
podría no reducirse hasta el objetivo
que están esperando las autoridades sino
hasta comienzos de 2025 dos años más con
precios altos Cuántos dolores de cabeza
Nos está dando la inflación pero hay
alguien que tiene buenas noticias es
china que registró un importante repunte
de su Comercio en el mes de marzo pues
eh mire Juan el valor en yuanes de los
bienes intercambios de los intercambios
comerciales entre China y el resto del
mundo aumentó 15,5% interanual en marzo
específicamente las exportaciones
subieron más del 23% y las importaciones
hicieron lo propio en un 6,1 %
interanual es decir marzo contra marzo
del año pasado la importancia de estos
datos radica en que china que es la
segunda economía más grande del mundo
está comenzando a sentir el impacto de
una demanda externa debilitada a medida
que la economía global se está
desacelerando Y eso afecta directamente
a socios comerciales tan claves como
Brasil que le provee gran parte de sus
materias primas momento para los
indicadores económicos
con optimismo después de que fuera
revelado el dato de índice de precios al
productor de marzo y cayó 0,5% respecto
al mes anterior y esto eleva las
apuestas de que la economía
efectivamente se está enfriando y que va
a permitir que la reserva Federal sea
menos estricta con sus tasas de interés
y en América Latina Argentina subió más
del 1%. en este país el precio del dólar
en el mercado informal que es al que los
ciudadanos acuden debido a las
restricciones que tienen para la compra
de dólares en el mercado oficial rompió
una nueva marca hoy llegó a los 400
pesos debido a una mezcla de factores
entre ellos la desconfianza a la moneda
local otro tema muy álgido siempre es el
tema del intercambio en Argentina
momento para nuestra cifra del día
5,65% subió la acción en la bolsa de
París de la casa matriz de Louis Vuitton
que también es dueña de otras firmas de
alta de alta gama como Tiffany y de la
que hablábamos ayer que había
incrementado en 17% sus ventas en el
primer trimestre
Pues gracias a este y otros ascensos en
la industria de lujo como Hermes o
l'oréal y el grupo Kevin que son
cercanos al 3% estos estas alzas el
principal índice del mercado francés
marcó y su tercer récord consecutivo
nuestra editora económica en Francia 24
en español Muchas gracias Nos vemos
mañana Así es nosotros continuamos aquí
en directo